next we're flying a zoom guest right
here under the desk and she's a comedian
an actor and a certified life of the
party
she first charmed us in the 90s with the
epic dating show singled out and now
she's a judge on the hit
show the math singer she is a friend
this is her second time here
[Applause]
[Music]
i've loved jenny for so long i'm so
lucky i mean amazing women i know and we
are here to honor your amazing launch of
your own
vegan
lip gloss
hi
jenny
[Applause]
beauty
i'm so proud of it can i just brag for a
second because
when i was the reason why i started it
was because when i started learning
about the ingredients in lip glosses i
was horrified horrified i was like wait
a minute i ingest lip gloss all day long
so i thought can i make something with
pure like real pure ingredients that is
vegan cruelty free that moisturizes your
lips you don't have like old lady cracky
lips and i did it and i'm so proud of it
and i named them after intention so
manifest dream love so i encourage
everyone to like
i love that with intent i love this
manifest dream and love you just a
little nothing here
[Applause]
oh i'm putting this up on my wall
immediately ditto saving thank you i
should have put a kiss on it
jenny would you be kind enough to do
some headlines with us i would love
nothing great
okay first up we've got a style trend
that is back from the dude and we want
your take on it jenny the wall street
journal reports that the denim tide has
turned and once again it is time for the
low rise gene oh god everyone's letting
their jeans hang a low lily rosa depp a
laurie harvey a haley bieber just a
couple of it girls jenny we're no
stranger to the old hip slip and denim
what are you gonna say we did we did
back in the day drew there you go i did
before i had two kids that's right and i
this is what i think of this new trend
no
no
no i have cellulite on my stomach i
can't at this age you know i just feel
so much better and that high-waisted i
can eat more you know and hold in at all
thank you
thank you
i would like a pair of jeans that go to
about here well
like where are those jeans
i mean this is why i'm wearing like yoga
pants and sweatpants every day because i
don't want to feel restricted but i mean
look look if i literally wore them now
it's like i would look like i'm kind of
pregnant like there's some meat there i
like just a like a where you know where
they measure your waist yeah that's
where i want my stuff to land hit me at
the waist well thank you jenny for your
amazing assessment yeah of those jeans i
agree
i don't see you two in those low-rise
jeans anytime soon you know some of us
are haunted by our uh past fashion
choices uh some of us are haunted too by
our past boyfriends girl can we uh can i
get an amen as rupaul says can i get it
amen
well uh let me explain in style reports
haunting is the latest dating trend so
you know ghosting is when someone
completely stops talking to you oh yeah
well haunting is when you feel the
lingering presence of an old flame on
your social media okay i love that yeah
so like you broke up but maybe he or she
is still commenting or liking your posts
and you're like what what oh my god i
totally have one of those
what not a boyfriend just someone i went
on a really weird date with and they're
still just right there and i'm like
why what
really
i'm in it right now ross my girlfriends
and i hate to call them out right now do
it but they are knee-deep into haunting
they've got fake accounts
because they were blocked already
that is a double no
oh yeah and literally they spend all day
long and sometimes if they find out
about the fake account then they're
calling me going can you check the page
right now i want to see if his
girlfriend got any skinnier i'm like
girl we're in our 40s what are you doing
let it go it happens but what's the
protocol if you break up say you were
someone for years and you break up do
you unfollow each other
yes yes
oh good good to know all right well
before we go
we took this show on the road to chicago
recently and while we were chomping down
on a delicious chicago hot dog at
jimmy's red hot
i met this most wonderful man a chicago
resident named tim
and it turns out
that tim said oh i watched the show
every day and i was like you do too
and i loved this man so much he is a
tattoo artist and i'd love for you to
check out some of his classic tattoos um
i loved this one
very graphic and alternative
um
yes and jenny chicago is your hometown
and i gotta tell you drew chicago loves
you my sister watches you every day she
was so excited she's like oh my gosh
we love you here well i highly recommend
you check out tattoo tim who is one of
our favorite viewers and we're so glad
that he came on board with this show
and you gotta just go to chicago and
love up on everything that it has to
offer including great miss jenny
mccarthy
[Applause]
the math singer is wednesday at 8
eastern 7 central on fox
[Music]